WHAT DO YA NNOVA CALL GOING
WELL I'D LIKE TO MEMBER A LIFE
TO SAY THAT THAT WERE WE JUST
OPEN THE ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE
HEARING ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
-- WAS VERY NICE TO STEP
DOWN FROM THE DAIS DRYNESS
AS OUR SUBSTITUTE FOR THE
DAY RIGHT NOW YEAH I DON'T
THINK YOU VANNATTER THIS TIME
WE'RE ALL HAVE -- WILL BE
CARRIED ONLY ONE DOES TODAY
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH QUORUM
QUIRK HERE MELENDEZ HERE
FRIEDMAN HERE I DON'T WANT
FAIRS ROBERT HOLDEN WHAT IT TO
CHEER ALRIGHT CORBIS PRESIDENT
WERE ALL HERE SAID THIS IS A
BILL THAT WE ALL VOTED FOR THE
FIRST TIME THREE SENATE HAS
PUT SOME AMENDMENTS AND -- AND
MISTER CHAIR WELL TELL US MORE
YEAH BRING MAYOR SYNDROME NO
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AUTOMOTIVE
COMING HERE I TOLD CHRIS UPON
WILL THINK THE SAMPLE WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL THIS I
GOT SO MANY PEOPLE TO TESTIFY
SO SUPPORT OFF THE BILL I'LL
MAKE MY PRESENTATION REALLY
RITUAL DISPELS OUR STRENGTH IN
THE TOOLS ALL FIVE EXPANDING
THE BOARD'S AUTHORITY TO
USE THAT IS CONSOLIDATION
AND ADMINISTRATORS AUTHORITY
TO SERVE DOMESTIC WELL AS A
REALLY SMALL WATER SYSTEMS AND
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE STATE BOARD
OF ADMINISTRATION OF DRINKING
WATER PROGRAM WAS SECURE
SAFE DRINKING WATER FOR SALSA
CALIFORNIA MOST VULNERABLE
COMEY FIENDS AND FOUND HERE
WITH ME TODAY BECAUSE HASN'T
QUITE USEFUL FOR ALL OF THOSE
IS EVENING RETURNS QUICKLY
GREENISH OF CONSOLE FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY OKAY LET
ME JUST SAY YOU'VE JUST STATED
THAT THEY HEALTH AS WE HAD
BEFORE WHY SHE STAYED WITH
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS DO OKAY
DISHONOR LOW AMENDMENT ALLOWED
THE STATE FOR TWO APPOINTED
AND CLARIFY THE ROLE OFTEN
ADMINISTRATORS TO HELP OVERSEE
AT FIRST SO THE FIRST THING
FIFTH SENATE FATE OF HOUSE
DOLLARS ASIA OVER APPROPRIATE
SECONDLY REQUIRING THE STATE
BOARD TO SET UP A PROCESS
THAT WILL ALLOW COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T HAVE SAFE GOING
TO AUTHORS TO PETITION LOS
CONSOLIDATION THIRDLY THE UP
AND JOINING THE CUSTOMER YOU
SEE DO WATER THROUGH A SOLID
DATA CONSOLIDATION ARE NOT
PAIN CHARGES OR FEES THAT ARE
HIGHER DANCE IS FEAR OR HIRED
AND OTHER CUSTOMER PAGE OF
COURSE SHORING CONSOLIDATION
OF AFFORDABILITY WHEN THE WAR
YOU KNOW PROFITS OF ORDERING
BECAUSE THEY AND A POINT HERE
AND THE MINISTRY THANK YOU MOVE
THE BILL SECOND REMOVED BY YOU
AND SECONDED BY THIS FRIEDMAN
FIVE OKAY PROCEED DALY CEO
LEADERSHIP THOUSAND FOR JUSTICE
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
SUPPORT STRUCTURE FOR MAKING
THE STILL IS BECAUSE IT IS HAVE
BEAUTIFUL ASSISTANCE FROM
ONE HUNDRED OKAY BUSINESS
ON PUBLIC AWARENESS ABOUT
YOU WANT TO OKAY SECRETARY
SEARCHING WATER ACTION
IS THERE ANY OTHER SPORT
NO SO THAN ANY OPPOSITION
ALL RIGHT THERE BEING
NO OPPOSITION YES MISTER
MAYOR SEARCH AND ATTACK THE
FROM THIS BILL NO THAT'S
GOOD TO KNOW ANYTHING
OKAY I ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
NO SOMETHING'S
YOU MAY JUST LAST ALRIGHT --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL TRY THIS IS MAYBE
TWENTY FIVE OH ONE KANSEN
CHU THE MOTION IS SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED QUIRK
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ AYE
MULLIN THIS AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE DEMAND ITEM ONE WEBSITE
BUT I'M GLAD I WROTE BRUNO
FOLDER FOLDED I WHAT'S WHICH I
IF MEANING IS OVER A HUNDRED